[موسيقى]
في ظل التطور الرقميه الذين يعيشوا حاليا
قد ينهزم اقوى جيوش العالم ليس في ميدان
المعركه فقط ولكن في ساحه الراي العامه
اهلا بكم في عسكري
[تصفيق]
الخارجيه الامريكيه توافق على صفقه شراء
استراليا 24 طائره من طراز سي 130 جيس
سوبر هركليز والتي تنتجها شركه لوكيد
مارتن الامريكيه هذه الصفقه تقدر باكثر من
6 مليارات و300 مليون دولار الصفقات تشمل
انظمه انذار صاروخيه وانظمه اخرى مضاده
للاشعه تحت الحمراء وكذلك معدات تكنولوجيه
اخرى اضافه الى الطائره
سلمت شركه
الطائره رقم 20 من طراز سي اتش 47 افا
شينوك الى سلاح الجو الملكي الهولندي
طائره سي اتش 47,000 هي طائره هليكوبتر
متقدمه ومتعدده المهام تحتوي على نظام
اداره قمره قياده رقمي متكامل كما تم
ترقيتها عن الاصدار السابق خاصه فيما
يتعلق بهيكل الطائره ونظام التحكم
التلقائي فيها
الجيش الكندي سيحصل على 39 مركبه مدرعه
خفيفه اضافيه من شركه جنرال دينمكس
الامريكيه مقابل 165 مليون دولار هذا بهدف
تعويض المعدات التي تبرعت بها كندا الى
اوكرانيا في وقت سابق من هذا العام كما
تخطط كندا ايضا لشراء انظمه كارلو ستار
المضاده للدبابات من الجيل الجديد لتحويل
لمحل الاسلحه القديمه التي شحنت الى
اوكرانيا
لسنوات كانت المملكه المتحده واحده من
اكثر الدول التي لديها درايه كبيره بطبيعه
التحالفات والنزاعات في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هذا الدور تقلص كثيرا خلال السنوات
الماضيه لكن بريطانيا الان يبدو وكانها
تحاول استعاده هذا الدور هذا من خلال
التعاون العسكري والتحالفات الامنيه مع
دول هذه المنطقه
بريطانيا هي واحده من الدول التي وصفت
تاريخيا بانها اكثر الدول درايه بهذه
المنطقه تحديدا منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا نظرا لتواجدها التاريخي في هذه
المنطقه لكن الدوره البريطاني تراجع خلال
السنوات الماضيه بعد تنامي الدور الامريكي
الان واشنطن يبدو ان لديها الكثير من
الملفات وهناك من يقول بان واشنطن او
الولايات المتحده اصبحت غير مهتمه بهذه
المنطقه على الجانب الاخر هناك ايضا من
يقول بان المملكه المتحده تسعى لاحياء
تحالفاتها داخل هذه المنطقه حول هذا
الموضوع معنا الفريق جوي مارتن سامسونج
كبير مستشار رئيس اركان الدفاع البريطاني
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا اولا فريق
سامسونج او فريق سامي كما تفضل همم اهلا
بك معنا في عسكريا همم واشنطن في هذه
الفتره يبدو انه لديها الكثير من الملفات
وبتت مشغوله اكثر الملف الصيني والملف
الروسي وكثير من الملفات الاخرى ولم تعد
يعني كما يقول بعض بتاعه طولي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط الاهميه الكافيه الان بريطانيا هل
تعود احياء تحالفاتها داخل هذه المنطقه هل
تسعى لاعاده ملئ هذا الفراغ
والروبوت سايز همم اود ان اقوله هو ان امن
الخليجي هو امنونه وان المملكه المتحده
لعبت على الدوام دورا مهما في المنطقه
ودائما مانولي اهميه لدورنا في المنطقه
وفي الوقت الذي نتحدث فيه الان لدينا
موظفون في مقررات قياده جويه في المنطقه
ومقرات قياده بحريه ولدينا مها مبريه
دائمه فيها ايضا وقد شاركنا في عمليات حلف
الناتو وفي مهام التحالف الدولي لمحاربه
داعش لذا فان التزامنا لا يزازه وسيبقى
كذلك على الدوام ولدينا نفس التهديدات
والمشاغل الامنيه المشتركه ونتشاطر فيما
بيننا بتاريخ مشترك فنحن اصدقاء واخوه
لعل لما تغير هو طريقه مزاوله اعمالنا
لكننا نوايانا واعمالنا تتسق تماما مع ما
كنا نقوم به منذ عقود من الزمن وسوف تستمر
على هذا المنوال في المستقبل ومقاربه بناء
على ما رايناه يوم هنا وما يتداوله الناس
عن موضوع التغيير فنجد احيانا ان التعاون
في المجال البحري هو الذي يكون مهيمنا
واحيانا في المجال الجوي او في مكافحه
الارهاب او المجالس سبراني لكننا سعداء
بكل تاكيد بان المملكه المتحده كانت على
الدوام صديقه لهذه المنطقه وستكون دائما
شريكا في المجال الامني ونشعر بالفخر
بالعلاقات التي تجمعنا مع شركنا والدور
الذي سمح لنا شركاؤنا وحلفاؤنا بان لعبه
هنا
روضه
[موسيقى]
او فريق سامي التهديدات التي تواجهها هذه
المنطقه هي تهديدات متعدده وبريطانيا كان
لها حضور تاريخ كبير حضور تاريخي كبير في
هذه المنطقه وعلى درايه بتفاصيل التحالفات
حتى الصغيره داخل هذه المنطقه برايك ما هي
ابرز التهديدات التي تواجهها من طاقه
الشرق الاوسط شمال افريقيا
[موسيقى]
اف 8
عدد كبير من التحديات والتهديدات التي
تواجه المنطقه هي ذاتها التي تواجهنا بصفه
طيارا ارى ان الامن البحريه يحظى باهميه
كبرى فهو مهم للقطاعات الصناعيه والتجاريه
في المنطقه ولامن الطاقه والامن الغذائي
ايضا كل هذه العوامل مهمه ودورنا يكمل في
حمايه المجالات الجويه والبحار التي تشكل
مصلحه مشتركه ومكافحه التطرف والارهاب
وانتشار التكنولوجيا التي قد تقعوا بيد
اناس الحلقه الاذى بشعوب المنطقه والشعب
البريطاني وبصوره عامه فهذه مهمه مشتركه
لنا جميعا وثمه تحدي يجب ان نتصدى له معا
ولعل المساله الاخرى هي سلامه الاراضي
ووحداتها في عمليات التهريب وتدفق السلاح
والمواد الاخرى بصوره غير مشروعه ونشر
الافكار في بلادي التي تؤدي الى زحزعه
الاستقرار لكي تثنيه عن الدوري البناء نود
منكم ان تلعبوه في المنطقه مساله مهمه من
ناحيه اخرى ثم تحديات وتهديدات تنبع من
العالم السبرالي والعمليات المتعلقه
بالمعلومات فبعض خصومنا واعدائنا يرغبون
في تحدي الطريقه التي نعيش بها وتحدي
طموحاتنا وتطورنا وقد يستخدمون كل السبل
في المجال السبراني والعمليات المعلوماتيه
من اجل التشهير بنا ومهاجمه مؤسساتنا
واضعافها وهذا مجال اخر منخرط به بشده من
اجل تقديم المساعده في حمايه شعوب المنطقه
والمصالح المشتركه وستشكل تركه للاجيال في
المستقبل
فريق سامي نصف المبيعات العسكريه
البريطانيه تذهب لدول منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لكن هذه الدول تغيرت في هذه المرحله وبتت
تسعى الى توطين الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه بداخلها الى اي مدى الحكومه
البريطانيه مستعده ان تسمح للشركات
البريطانيه العامله في هذا المجال ان
تشارك دول وشركات هذه المنطقه التكنولوجيا
والافكار خاصه بان هذا يشكل عائق كبير
امام الشركات في هذه المنطقه في هذه
المرحله
نعم هذا رائع فاننا ومن صميم قلوبنا ندعم
طموحات اصدقاءنا في المنطقه والجزء الاكبر
ويتمثل في اعطاء الفرصه لشبابكم من اصحاب
المواهب والمثقفين التوطين هو مبدا سانده
في مجال نقل التكنولوجيا بحيث تتسنى لنا
مساعده اصدقائنا في بناء قدراتهم وهذا
المبدا كان على الدوام من الاولويات التي
نقوم بها منذ فتره طويله وهذا امر لن
يخيفنا خاصه عندما نرى ثمار التي سوف
نحصدها مع اصدقائنا وهذه السمه الرئيسيه
التي نراها هنا في المنفعه المشتركه في
مجال نقل التكنولوجيا وتوطينها وعندما
يتحدث اناس كثر عن نقل التكنولوجيا في
اتجاه واحد في سياق مساعدتنا للشعوب لكي
تبني صناعاتها والتكنولوجيا الخاصه بها
فضلا عن الهيكله الخاصه بها التي تتناسب
مع بلدانهم ومنطقه لابد ان يدركوا ان نقل
هذه التكن سيعود بالخير على المملكه
المتحده فما يجمعنا هو العلاقه المتينه
وثقه التي تجعلنا نستفيد معا من
التكنولوجيا بحيث نستطيع ابتكارها بصوره
مشتركه وليس فقط نقلها بل تطويرها مع
شركائنا بهدف المنفعه المشتركه وهذا
امتداد منطقي لمجابه التحديات وتعزيز
الطموحات وهذا يجب ان يكون هدفنا
فالتكنولوجيا في البحرين التي تم تطويرها
بصوره مشتركه مع المملكه المتحده وتستخدم
فيها لن تقل اهميه عن تلك التي تم تطويرها
في صوره مشتركه في المملكه المتحده ويتم
استخدامها في البحر البحرين
فريق سامي يعني انت كنت احد قاده القوه
الجويه الملكيه البريطانيه ولكن خبره
كبيره في هذا المجال حلقت اكثر من 500
لكن الان الحرف في اوكرانيا هناك الكثير
من الدروس الاستراتيجيه يعني اعلى من
مستوى القوات البريه والقوات الجويه
والقوه الدفاع الجوي لكن بالنسبه للقوات
الجويه ما هو الدرس الاستراتيجي الاهم من
الحرب الدائره ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
الان الذي تضعونه دائما في حساباتكم كقاده
وتدرسون وحتى في
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لصغار المتدربين او
صغار التيارين
هناك دروس كثيره يمكننا ان نستقي العبر
منها من الغزو الروسيه الجائر لاوكرانيا
ولعل الدرسه الرئيسيه هو ان الاصدقاء
والشركاء ذوي التفكير المتشابه عليهم ان
يتكاتفوا كحلفاء عند حدوث مثل هذه الاشياء
ولهذا فاننا فخورون بعلاقاتنا وصداقتنا مع
شركائنا في المنطقه لانه في بعض الاحيان
قد يرفض الناس المبادئ التي تجمعنا مثل
مصالحنا القوميه المشتركه وقدرتنا على منح
شعوبنا حياه مزدهره مسالمه وحتى انهم قد
يتحدون سلامه فضائنا الجوي السيادي
واراضينا ومجالنا استمراني ويرفضون ان
يكون الدوله التي نصب اليها وطموحاتنا
والدرس الاكبر الذي تعلمناه وانه يجب
علينا ان نكون اكثر لحمه مع الحلفاء
والاصدقاء الذين يشاطرون نفس التفكير
ويرغبون بالعمل وفقا لم تحكمها القواعد
الدوليه ويتصرفون بطريقه تتسم بالمسؤوليه
في العالم لقد تم بناء تلك الصداقات
والثقه والتحالفات على مر سنوات طويله
ولعل هذا يعزز بشده مدى اهميه تحالفاتنا
في المنطقه ومن منظور القوه الجويه لابد
من السيطره على المجال الجوي فان فشلت في
السيطره على المجال الجوي سيكون شعبك عرضه
للتهديدات وينسحب ذلك الى قدرتك على ضمان
الامن الغذائي وامن الطاقه وللقوه الجويه
دور مهم لتلعبه في تامين الحياه من الجو
ونقطه منطقيه اخيره في هذا الخصوص هناك
خطر داهم في نشر التكنولوجيا بطريقه تخلو
من المسؤوليه كما هو الحاله بالنسبه
للمسيرات وغيرها من الاسلحه الاخرى لذا
لدينا شركات في مجال الامن البحري وامن
الحدود وتعد الشركات الامنيه تلك مهمه
للغايه حتى في مجال المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بحيث نمنع الذين يرغبون في
الحاق الاذى والضرر ببلداننا وشعوبنا
والبلدان الاخرى ومؤسساتها من فعلتهم لابد
لنا ان نمنعهم من قدره الوصول الينا او
منشن حرب او الحصول على التكنولوجيا ومن
ثم شن حرب علينا لابد لنا ان نتصرف بسرعه
خشيه ان يباغتنا ذلك
الفريق جوي مارتن سامسونج كبير المستشار
الرئيس اركان الدفاع البريطانيه للشرق
الاوسط هو شمال افريقيا شكرا جزيلا همم
على ذلك شكرا
[تصفيق]
يترقب العسكريون في الولايات المتحده خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله مصير التجارب على
طائره الهليكوبتر المستقبليه للجيش
الامريكي هذه الطائره التي تعمل عليها
اكبر شركه لطائرات في الولايات المتحده
سكراسكي
المروحيه ديفاينكس التي من المقرر ان تحل
محل طائره البلاك هوك مع حلول عام 2005
لتنفيذ مهام هجوميه بعيده المدى للجيش
الامريكي الطائره ذات المحركين تتميز
بطبقتين من المراوح على سطحها وكذلك
مروحيه صغيره في مؤخرتها هذه المراوح
ستمنحها قدره كبيره على المناوره والطيران
في اتجاهات مختلفه وايضا بزوايا ضيقه
يتوقع ان تكون اسرع من طائره البلاك هوك
بسرعه تتجاوز 2004 عقده من دون حموله و100
عقده وهي بحمولتها القصوى هذه طائره ايضا
ستكون قاد على قطع ضعفي المسافه التي
تقطعها طائرات البلاك هوك بمقدار يصل الى
700 ميل من دون الحاجه لتزود بالوقود في
الجو كما ان شركه الترا هاريس الامريكيه
ستقوم بتزويد هذه المروحيه باجهزه الرادار
ومنظومات الاستشعار والمقاعد
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل احتدام الجدل العلميه حول
استخدام الذكاء الصناعي في الصناعات
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مع تزيد الاستخدامات
العسكريه للذكاء الصناعي في مجال الصناعات
العسكريه وكذلك ظهور اسلحه ذاتيه التوجيه
تتصاعد المخاوف على الجانب الاخر من خروج
هذه الاله عن السيطره سواء فعل قصور
تكنولوجي او هجمات سيبراني لكن السؤال كيف
يرى العلماء هذه المخاوف وكذلك كيف
يستعدون للتعامل معها
[تصفيق]
للوقوف اكثر حول تفاصيل التطور الذي تم في
تقنيه الروبوتات حول العالم يشرفنا ان
يكون لنا هذا اللقاء مع البروفيسور اسامه
الخطيب استاذ علوم الحاسب ومدير معهد
الروبوتات في جامعه استانفرد بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يفسر اسامه اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريا اهلا بك استاذ اسامه يعني
اجمالا في شكل موجز ابرز الانجازات التي
حدثت في مجال الروبوتات حتى هذه اللحظه
عن الروبوتات التي كانت تستخدم في
القطاعات الصناعيه والتصنيع وتدريجيا خرجت
الروبوتات عن هذا الاطار لتدخل في عالم من
الحقيقي وهذا تسبب في تحديات كبيره على
الروبوتاتها وفي نفس الوقت توفر امكانيات
المدهشه لتقديم الروبوتات لمساعده
البشريهم ونسمي تلك الروبوتات بالمنزلي
ومساعده العمال والتفاعل مع البيئات
المعقده المختلفه مثلا اذا ما اردنا
المشاركه في عمليات خاصه بهزه ارضيه او
اذا تعذر ارسال البشري بشكل امن داخل مبنى
فسنستطيع ان نرسل الروبوتات هناك تطبيقات
عديده فقد بدانا مؤخرا ببذل جهود كبيره في
الروبوتات تحت المياه التي سمحت باستكشاف
عوالم نعرف عنها اقل مما نعرفه عن القمر
او حتى المريخ والمحيطات كما تعرفون تمثل
نحو 70% من كوكبنا ولا يمكن ان نغتصدون
المئه متر تحت مياهها كل ذلك جلب
تكنولوجيا جديده لمساعده البيئه والعالم
وكذلك البشر
[موسيقى]
ولكن يبدو انه لم تعد المجالات الانسانيه
فقط هي التي يعني
الروبوتس في هذه المرحله يعني الان
الروبوت تدخل بشكل كبير جدا في التقنيه
عالم السلاح انت كمتم بهذا المجال
وبروكسير كبير في هذا المجال هل لديك
تخوفات من دخول الروبوتس في هذا الخط خط
تصنيع الدفاعات العسكريه
وهمم ضلافه
قانون الروبوتات ينص على ان الروبوتات يجب
ان تقدم الخيره للبشر وليسائهم وهناك
نقاشات واسعه حول مساله استخدام الروبوتات
لاغراض عسكريه هناك مسائل واخلاقيه عديده
مرتبطه باستخدام الروبوتات وحقيقه ان
الروبوتات بدات تقترب في عملها من البشر
تسبب تحديات عديده كيف يمكن ان يكون هناك
تفاعل امن بين اله يمكن ان تكون خطيره
وانسان واذا ما حدث خلل في اجهزه السيطره
يمكن ان يؤدي ذلك الى ضرر بالبيئه التي
يعمل فيها الروبوت او حتى اصابته انسان كل
هذه المسائل بات جزء اساسيا من اسلوب
التفكير الجديد بتطبيقات الروبوتات وهناك
تخوف من الروبوتات يتجاوز بخاوف افلام
الخيال العلمي وهذا يشمل اصول الروبوتات
الى مراحل ذكاء متقدمه تمكنها من
الاستيلاء على وظائفنا وعلى كوكبنا وتتحكم
بكل شيء ولكنني اود ان اطمئنكم بار
الاشخاص الذين يعملون مع الروبوتات
والاجهزه المتقدمه بعيدون جدا عن هذه
القدرات واذا ما كان هناك اي شك حول سلوك
الروبوتات فبامكاننا فصلها عن الطاقه عن
روبت قوي
مثل الطائرات المسيره او مركبات التنقل
فهي تختلف عن الروبوتات التي نتحدث عنها
التي لديها اذرع وايد تؤدي الواجبات
والاعمال اما الالات المسلحه فهي مختلفه
وهي موجوده اصلا فاذا ما تاملنا في
الطائرات العسكريه فهي بمثابه الروبوتات
عاملين
في الشرق الاوسط بروفيسور اسامه نحن
بعيدين جدا عن هذا المجال في هذه المرحله
يعني هناك خطوات ولكنها خطوه ما زالت تبدو
ضعيفه في بعض الاحيان وبسيطه في احيان
اخرى كيف تقيم التقدم في مجال الروبوتات
في الشرق الاوسط وما هي ال- ال- الخطوات
التي يجب ان يتم اتخاذها في الشرق الاوسط
وفي دول الشرق الاوسط حتى يكون هناك صناعه
واضحه وتقدم واضح في هذا المشعر
اشتركت في اول مؤتمر روبوتات عربي في عمان
بالاردن وسعدت جدا لاطلاق برنامج مثل هذا
الذي جمع ممثلين من العالم العربي باكمله
للمشاركه واذكر محادثاتي مع الطلبه الذين
حضروا الاجتماعات وقلت لهم ان لدينا عقول
نيره في العالم العربي واشخاص مميزين
لديهم امكانيات رائعه لاجراء الابحاث في
مجالات مختلفه من ضمنها الروبوتات ولكن
للاسف ليست لديهم الفرصه للقيام بذلك بسبب
صعوبه الحصول على المختبرات والادوات
والبيئه المطلوبه وانا سعيد جدا لرؤيه ما
يجري في دول الخليج وبعض المؤسسات في
مراكز الابحاث في العالم العربيه حيث
بدانا باجراء الابحاث في تلك المجالات
وعلوم الروبوتات معقده لانها تتطلب
الروبوتات والبنت التحتيه ولكنني اعتقد
حقا ان جيلنا لديه القدرات لتذليل كل هذه
التحديات الخاصه بالابحاث دون اي صعوبه
اذا مات سنه لهم الفرس انا واثق ومتفائل
بالمستقبل سواء امرلك
[تصفيق]
واحده من انجح طائرات التجسس الاستراتيجي
في تاريخ سلاح الجو الامريكي تزامن خروجها
من الخدمه مع بدء تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتيه
طائره اي اس ار 71
هذه الطائره انتجتها شركه لوكيد مارتن
الامريكيه كجزء من مشروع سري لتصنيع
طائرات يصعب رصدها على شاشات الرادار شكلت
حينها ثوره في صناعه الطائرات افضت لاحقا
الى انتاج المقاتلات الشبحيه دخلت البلاك
بيرد الخدمه في عام
1966 تم تصنيع اثنتين وثلاثين طائره منها
لصالح سلاح الجو الامريكي وكذلك وكاله
ناسا الفضائيه ولم تصدر هذه الطائره لاي
جهه خارج الولايات المتحده نظرا لحساسيه
التكنولوجيا التي تتمتع بها هذه الطائره
بلغت سرعتها النحو اربعه الاف كيلو متر في
الساعه اي كانت حينها اسرع من اي صاروخ
ارض جو كما بلغ معدل ارتفاعها نحو 26 الف
متر ما جعلها بعيده عن تهديد المقاتلات
والصواريخ
زود الطائره البلاك بيرد بافضل ما توفر
حينها من منظومات التنصت الالكترونيه
وكذلك منظومات الرادار لكشف التحركات
الجويه في محيطها وايضا تم تزويدها
بكاميرات لمراقبه الاهداف البعيده
اعلن عن تقاعد طائره البلاد بيرد في عام
1989 لكن تم اعاده هذه الطائره للخدمه
لفتره وجيزه في منتصف التسعينيه لتخرج
بعدها نهائيا من الخدمه في عام
1998 كما انهت وكاله ناسا الفضائيه خدمات
هذه الطائره ايضا في مجال البحث العام في
عام 1999
[موسيقى]
حلقه عسكريه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]